c'était infiltré à Auschwitz un film
absolument indispensable réalisé par
tenance pack et Maya Anaïs yatagen merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et juste à vos côtés il y a
tal brutman vous a reconnu on vous a vu
évidemment dans ce documentaire vous
êtes le conseiller scientifique du film
que l'on vient de voir historien et
spécialiste de la Shoah merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation
enfin surtout l'invitation de la seconde
4 du lycée Henri IV bonjour les élèves
alors vous avez évidemment travailler
sur ce film vous l'avez regardé
plusieurs fois de nombreuses fois mais
tout d'abord j'aimerais connaître un
petit peu votre sentiment
s'il y avait un mot pour définir pour
résumer ce que vous avez ressenti quand
vous l'avez vu la première fois qu'elle
serait-il
oui Paul de l'admiration je pense pour
pour piliers de ski qui a quand même
accompli un acte
héroïque mais qui n'est peut-être qui
n'est pas assez reconnu en tout cas je
ne le connaissais pas avant de se dire
que ça a pu exister et de voir tant de
preuves tant d'information
impressionnante c'est toujours vraiment
surréaliste de dire comment c'est
possible que ça a pu exister peut-être
sentiment de frustration que comme elle
dit Paul un homme pareil ne soit pas
plus reconnu car c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on voit très souvent une personne qui
est prête à se porter volontaire pour
une expérience aussi horrible et le voir
c'est c'est de l'admiration mais c'est
aussi un grand sentiment de frustration
surtout quand on liste toutes les choses
qu'il a parcouru ça fait mal on se dit
quand même que c'est peut-être pas
normal qu'une personne qui a fait des
choses aussi héroïque et que et des
choses on va dire aussi
décisives aussi pour l'histoire même si
on a vu que
mais qui dans l'initiative était très
très héroïque et très marquante n'a pas
pu tenir au fil de l'histoire est-ce que
ce documentaire vous a permis de mesurer
encore plus l'horreur des camps nazis
oui c'est connu comme étant le camp de
concentration dont on entend parler et
là c'est l'un des premiers rapports
qu'on a à Auschwitz et c'est quand même
incroyable qu'on en est jamais entendu
parler parce qu'il est
réaliste et poignant allez c'est à vous
de poser des questions à nos invités et
on commence par toi Paul je crois que tu
as une première question à poser
de ski donc il s'agit il s'agit d'un
sujet qui est quand même assez assez
précis et je pense que qu'aucun de nous
n'en avait entendu parler comment
avez-vous découvert qu'ils et une fois
que vous l'avez découvert comment vous
vous êtes venu cette idée vraiment d'en
faire un documentaire alors moi j'étais
un peu comme vous à l'école à Paris on
m'a jamais parlé du stop list es et
pourtant je suis d'origine polonaise et
là aussi on m'a jamais parlé de Little
pileski après ma mère il est un peu
après la guerre donc il y a toute
l'histoire qu'on vous raconte à la fin
du film on comprend pourquoi est-ce que
à l'école on lui a pas dit regarde ce
que quelqu'un a fait en Pologne quelques
années avant toi quoi c'est mon coeur et
Coréal ta danse Pâques qui en fait
faisait un film sur auschwitch un autre
sujet et qui est un peu par hasard et
tombé sur
cette mention de ce nom il s'est un peu
intéressé il est un peu un peu gratté et
puis c'est rendu compte que le rapport
de Vitold avait été récemment traduit en
français et il a acheté et là
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dit
cette histoire elle peut pas elle peut
pas rester comme ça dans un dans un
autre filet dans un dans un journal quoi
si on a la possibilité de de saisir le
temps qui nous reste avec la famille de
Little pileski parce que vous voyez
qu'ils sont pas ils sont pas tout jeunes
c'était main donc jamais du coup on a eu
la chance de rencontrer de rencontrer la
famille pilatski pour pouvoir donner un
peu plus de résonance à cette histoire
et notamment notamment en France Jean
comment se fait-il que Vital pileetzki
soit si peu connu alors vital piletzky
vous l'avez vu dans le film c'était un
officier qui est rentré dans la
Résistance et ensuite qui a réussi à
s'échapper à Auschwitz et qui après
Auschwitz a connu la Pologne sous le
joues soviétique sous le joug communiste
derrière le rideau de fer donc il
continue de résister et continuer de
résister après la guerre
faut choisir son camp quoi c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est mainstream pour le
gouvernement en place derrière le rideau
de fer quoi donc c'est pour ça que cet
homme il a arrêté il est jugé pour
trahison il fusillé et il devient
personnel c'est une histoire horrible
pour ses enfants pour pour zophia pour
Angel c'est ils sont ils sont c'est
au-delà de la tester quoi on déjà il
veut devenir pilote et on lui dit pilote
alors que ton père c'est le chef des
traîtres polonais hors de question hors
de question Zofia on la convoque en
disant voilà ton père on limite on va
passer le procès à la radio pour que tu
entendes bien à quel point est-ce que
c'est un traître enfin il est au-delà de
ville il est tombé c'est quelqu'un qui
est vu comme le traître ultime de la
nation polonaise donc forcément son son
histoire tant que le rideau de fer ne
tombe pas tant que le mur de Berlin de
Tom pas elle peut pas exister en Pologne
et ce n'est qu'après 1990 que là suite
au témoignages d'historien aussi de
personnes qui ont résisté et qui ont
fait un travail extraordinaire pour dire
bah oui il y avait une résistance dans
les camps il y avait une résistance
polonaise
qui ont permis de réhabiliter ce nom de
Little piletzky et donc de lui faire
encore une fois hommage en permettant à
cette histoire d'exister hors des
rapports qui auraient pu se perdre au
fur et à mesure du temps
Carla je crois que tu as une question
pour tal bruttman
y a-t-il eu des chercheurs ou alors
d'autres réalisateurs qui se sont
vraiment penchés sur cette histoire
alors cette histoire est quand même
largement connue parce que quand vous
dit depuis tout à l'heure cette histoire
ne nous est pas connu c'est normal vous
êtes français à Paris et des grandes
figures de la Résistance polonaise vous
en connaissez aucune c'est normal de va
avoir deux ou quatre heures sur la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et l'histoire de
la Shoah déjà c'est ça Auschwitz c'est
une toute petite partie et les individus
là-dedans c'est rien du tout mais pile
et ski maintenant c'est une super star
en Pologne il fait partie de tout un
ensemble de figures de la Résistance
polonaise qui ont été étudiées surtout
comme maladie à la fin des années 90
quand le régime communiste est tombé
pour simplifier les choses
pouvoir communiste donc il y a que la
Résistance communiste qui est célébrée
la résistance nationale elle n'existe
pas c'est tous des traîtres c'est
l'extrême droite en gros si vous suivez
l'actualité aujourd'hui avec ce qui se
passe en Ukraine vous savez que les
Russes expliquent que les Ukrainiens
sont tous des néonazis les communistes
expliquaient que les militants de
l'accueil étaient tous des fascistes
même logique du coup pileetzky était
connu mais à l'ouest paradoxalement même
s'ils sont son témoignage n'était pas
connu il y a des morceaux de témoignages
qui ont été publiés à Londres fin 42 qui
venait de piliers de ski par le
gouvernement polonais donc il avait
inexistence chez les historiens
c'est-à-dire nulle part et à partir de
la fin des années 90 sa figure a
commencé à être découverte à être étudié
parmi un ensemble beaucoup plus large
mais aujourd'hui pile et ce qui est une
figure de proue
mais comme je l'ai dit au départ
vraiment avec des usages multiples c'est
un authentique résistant vraiment c'est
une magnifique figure de la Résistance
polonaise de l'armière cryova la tia
c'est-à-dire l'armée du peuple fin du
pays mais en même temps il y a mais
comme dans tous les pays surtout les
pays qui sont dirigés par un régime d'un
extrême ou d'un autre il y a un usage
une manipulation plus ou moins volonté
souvent volontaire du passé en faveur
d'un discours qui est mis en place
est-ce que vous pensez que aujourd'hui
le fait d'aborder la Seconde Guerre
mondiale d'un point de vue français peut
poser problème pour la représentation
qu'on a de cette époque et est-ce que si
oui est-ce que vous avez une autre
manière de l'aborder est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous aimerez modifier on
va dire la question elle est censée elle
est fondée mais déjà
la Seconde Guerre mondiale aujourd'hui
dans les programmes ça représente
quasiment plus rien mais vraiment donc
il y a une sorte de distorsion entre la
place que ça occupe dans le politique
paouse c'est pas péjoratif dans le
politique dans le mémorial mais pas plus
le mémorial pouvait prendre les hommes
politiques les uns et les autres ils se
taquent tous de se draper dans cette
histoire là du président de la
République jusqu'à par exemple Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui se balade avec un petit
triangle rouge qui renvoie aux détenus
des camps de concentration donc il se
drape tous dans cette histoire-là donc
il y a cette posture et après il y a la
réalité de ce qui est court c'est que
plus ça va plus la place de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale dans les programmes elle
disparaît donc là il y a un vrai
problème que personne ne pointe parce
que ça fait des années que c'est comme
ça pour le coup que je pointe là grâce à
votre question maintenant la question
initiale c'était le point de vue on va
dire français par rapport à d'autres
points de vue le problème c'est que en
ayant moins de deux heures pour la
seconde guerre mondiale
quel point de vue alors il y a plein de
choses qui pourraient être abordées
évidemment
mais déjà il faut faire des choix en
plus et ce qui est intéressant dans vos
commentaires à propos du documentaire
c'est vous connaissiez pas pilier de ski
mais vous connaissez pas non plus aux
fuites enfin vous connaissez le nom mais
vous connaissez pas où je suis auschwitt
de tous les sites de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale c'est le plus compliqué de tout
ça comprendre et pourtant c'est celui
qui en permanence
utilisé comme exemple alors qu'il est
ultra complexe et la question de savoir
de quel point de vue on parle de
l'événement c'est une excellente
question mais en même temps c'est
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour aborder
cet événement là vu par différents
prismes par un enfant polonais par
exemple par rapport on est en France il
est logique qu'on parle de notre
histoire avant tout qui participe de la
construction de notre estime nationale
ce qui est normalement chaque pays
et ensuite si un sujet vous intéresse
vous pouvez l'élargir vous comment vous
êtes parvenu à trouver toutes les
archives photographiques de pileetzky et
des camps de concentration centre
d'extermination et est-ce que vous avez
eu recours aux archives de Lina alors
Lina pas trop parce que un peu comme
voilà on va pas ni de vidéo ni de photos
qui traînent sur France 2 ou autre
télévision française de l'époque en fait
c'est des archives qui viennent de la
famille après il y a plusieurs photos
qu'on a récupéré aussi via IPN
l'Institut pour la mémoire nationale aux
choses comme ça et donc eux ils ont un
fond de photos donc ils ont fait tout le
travail forcément ils ont récupéré
toutes les photos de la naissance
jusqu'à une photo du procès donc tout ça
aussi on les a récupérés pour tout ce
qui est photo des camps on est passé par
le musée de berkana qui a été
extraordinaire juste incroyable
incroyable de de gentillesse de de
service de rapidité dans la dans la
précision la plus la plus absolue et il
y a beaucoup de photos comment j'avais
jamais vu jamais même des trucs que
j'avais même pas que c'est vraiment que
ça existait donc ils ont été incroyables
et il y avait aussi un énorme mémorial
aux États-Unis qui a un site internet
extrêmement bien fourni avec beaucoup de
vidéos tout ça ça vient ça vient de mais
c'est du coup c'est pas l'hiver Arthur
on t'écoute comment vous êtes vous
préparer avant de vous lancer dans le
tournage c'est beaucoup de lecture en
français en anglais beaucoup de lecture
en polonais par ma mère qui a beaucoup
traduites beaucoup expliqué de trucs
donc beaucoup beaucoup de recherches
donc c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on s'est
qu'on s'est préparé au-delà de de faire
le repérage un peu classique de où
est-ce qu'on va les tourner est-ce qu'on
va aller à Varsovie évidemment on va
aller Auschwitz aussi de recherche de la
famille parce qu'on voulait on voulait
témoignages donc pour pour avoir le
moyen le souvenir leur version leur
émotion aussi j'espère donc c'était
aussi les retrouver et de les convaincre
tel Brugmann comment s'organise le
conseil scientifique sur un documentaire
comme celui-ci est-ce que vous vérifiez
chaque plan vous écoutez chaque
témoignage où vous avez une vision
seulement d'ensemble à la fin expliquer
nous comment vous travaillez moi je fais
rien
quand même c'est eux qui ah non c'est
eux qui bossent et à la fin je leur dis
si ça va ou si ça va pas que tu sois en
cohérence avant même la cohérence
intellectuelle il y a déjà que ça colle
vraiment c'est à dire qu'une photo qui
soit pas mal légendée soit utilisé alors
que ça a rien à voir régulièrement il y
a des documentaires où je dis il faut
enlever la photo parce qu'elle n'a rien
à voir avec cette période là où cette
personne avec le sujet
mais des fois sur un documentaire mais
c'était un autre mais c'est même pas de
leur faute c'était marqué Auschwitz sur
la photo qu'ils avaient sélectionné dans
un centre d'archives et c'était pas du
tout ok donc rien à faire là donc voilà
donc déjà il y a ça pareil sur des
témoignages il y a des témoins qui
peuvent mais c'est la règle de tout
témoignage qui peuvent dire quelque
chose qui n'est pas correct ou il se
mélange les pinceaux avec une autre
période donc faut dire non là l'extrait
que vous avez sélectionné pas bon faut
couper avant ou choisir un autre donc
c'est même pas là la cohérence du on va
dire de ce que livre le documentaire en
général c'est deux trois visionnage et
un visionnage final une fois que ce que
moi j'ai éventuellement dit sont
intégrés après il y a une validation
enfin voilà comment ça fonctionne en
général comprendre votre implication
dans ce type de travail très particulier
c'est vrai que c'était une grande
angoisse sans tu as le droit de mal hein
tellement je n'aurais jamais présenté
quoi que ce soit enfin je il y a
vraiment un truc de c'est pas n'importe
quel sujet c'est la véracité en tant que
tel quoi me demander en voyant le
documentaire comment avez-vous vécu
émotionnellement la réalisation d'un
film sur un sujet aussi dur
je pense que
blinde un peu parce que sinon comment
est-ce que comment on avance dans les
archives et les témoignages puis moi mon
expérience d'avoir travaillé sur un
sujet aussi dur c'est tellement rien
comparé à ceux qui l'ont vécu du coup je
pense avec beaucoup d'humilité mais
sinon et c'est ça peut ça peut
potentiellement être un peu compliqué
ils essayaient de nous atteindre de
façon radicale de nous briser
mentalement
les SS riait
le tortionnaires tout en nous frappant
en criait
[Musique]
avec les autres hommes
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'arriver sur un
lieu où tant d'horreur ont été commises
parce qu'un lieu en soi même ça parle
pas donc si vous avez pas vu le
documentaire puis que vous avez eu juste
votre cours sur la Shoah et la Seconde
Guerre mondiale vous connaissez pas
grand chose donc vous allez vous
représenter plein de choses et vous
allez les vivre de plein de façons
différentes il y a pas de règle sur ce
qu'on vit quand on visite un site mais
arrivé sur le site en soit ça veut pas
dire grand chose c'est ce que vous
connaissez du site ou ce qu'on vous
explique pendant la visite du site qui
permet de comprendre un certain nombre
d'éléments si on vous met au Louvre sans
explication vous voyez les tableaux mais
vous savez pas à quoi correspond le
musée du Louvre ni son histoire je veux
dire avant d'être un musée etc etc voilà
donc en ce sens là un site ça ne parle
pas ensuite c'est très particulier parce
qu'il y a cette idée que si on va au
Schwitz on va comprendre le mal et donc
on va devenir individuellement bon
et on va soi-même lutter contre le mal
ce qui relève une sorte de
pensée positive totalement absurde il y
a plein de gens pas bien qui vont à
Auschwitz les SS ont travaillé 5 ans à
Auschwitz ça n'aurait pas poser de
problème au quotidien donc ce rapport
aussi qu'il est il est passablement
vicié par la centralité qui l'occupe en
fait c'est pas qu'on parle pas assez de
shit c'est souvent j'insiste là-dessus
on en parle mal on en parle mal parce
que on est sûr qu'on en parle bien qu'on
connaît et parce qu'on connaît on va en
parler sans faire des hors saints
vraiment c'est un des sujets les plus
compliqués qui soit sur la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et vous Maya j'y suis
allée alors que je commençais à
travailler sur sur le documentaire parce
que je ne voulais pas lors du tournage
arriver et
m'écrouler donc j'ai tiré ma gentille
maman parce que je voulais aussi faire
ça faire ça avec elle et découvrir ce
lieu mais ça résonne beaucoup ce que
vous dites parce qu'on a eu je pense de
visites très différentes
elle et moi moi avec
mes lectures du moment mes connaissances
qui commençaient à s'accumuler et elle
qui avait certainement moins ça et qui
était plus peut-être un peu perdu moi
j'avais presque l'impression de de
coller tout ce que j'avais lu sur ces
lieux vides limitent les sons comment ça
quoi que ma mère que ma mère évidemment
avait pas ça mais plus de distancier
peut-être peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on
ressent quand on quand on met les pieds
là-bas la première fois
on ressent une grande émotion et un
petit côté aussi
absurdité de l'homme parce qu'il y a des
gens qui font des selfies il y a des
gens qui sont même s'ils ont pas le
droit il y a des gens qui fument même
s'ils n'ont pas le droit il y a plein de
trucs comme ça et ça ça sort un peu de
l'entendable c'est on il y a un problème
de respect de ce qui s'est passé
peut-être de compréhension aussi de ce
qui s'est passé et du coup c'est c'est
très étrange d'avoir à la fois cette
émotion cette mémoire d'être sur les
lieux évidemment il y a l'expérience
entre guillemets visite à Auschwitz 1 et
birkana vraiment enfin c'est on prend
une petite navette c'est très
surréaliste on arrive à l'autre endroit
et là en fait en soi on voit pas grand
chose on voit des leviers les petites
baraques c'est ce que vous voyez les
plans de drone se vant aussi enfin je
sais c'est c'est le vide et si on n'a
pas lu si on sait pas c'est
c'est un lieu on va poursuivre avec
Arthur qui est juste ici c'est une
question par rapport au dessin qui
accompagne le documentaire pour savoir
en fait d'où viennent-ils dans le sens
de via quelle source en fait vous les
êtes fourni
l'idée de départ c'était que en faisant
le la biographie de je me suis rendu
compte qu'il dessinait beaucoup c'était
un homme très créatif et on se retrouve
donc à faire ce film ou évidemment qu'on
va pas mettre autre chose en image on va
pas s'amuser à faire des reconstitutions
donc on ces images là où je suis très
sobrement et pareil au cours de mes
recherches sur le site d'Achille de
berkana je découvre une petite brochure
la rauschwitz et là non plus
spécialiste mais il y avait une
exposition sur il y a deux types d'art
il y a l'art soit imposé par les nazis
il y avait un musée Schwitz soit au
clandestin donc il y avait des formes
d'arachitz et il y avait des oeuvres
d'art qui ont été faites par les
prisonniers survivants c'est comme ça
qu'on a pu rajouter en plus cette
sensibilité de la personne qui qui a vu
vécu
expérimenter l'horreur dans
et survivre et essayer de survivre aussi
par là et voilà eux ils ont montré par
leur dessin leur peinture parce que
c'était sans que nous on est à ajouter
quoi que ce soit ou voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on a utilisé ces dessins à propos la
question de la musique j'ai eu
l'impression en regardant le
documentaire qu'il y avait vraiment un
souci sur sur le son notamment sur la
place du silence et des fois aussi à un
moment il me semble qu'on entend un
bruit de porte un grand un grincement
sur 8 est-ce que vous avez vraiment fait
attention à ça
[Rires]
c'est mon moment dans le film oui
effectivement avec le travail
extraordinaire de notre monteuse en fait
on est on est en salle de montage et on
et on a vraiment fait attention au
silence aussi et à l'ambiance qu'on a pu
aussi ressentir sur place
chaque bâti s'abrite jusqu'à 1200
prisonniers
qui s'entassent pendant des mois sur le
sol
puis dans des lits qu'ils auront
construit
ils sont plusieurs par niveau
les vivants
partage leur couche avec les mourant
vous assistiez à l'agonie prolongée de
votre ami
c'était comme mourir avec lui votre
existence cessait aussi
les portes les petits grincements les
pas en fait il y a différents baraques
différents
qui sont pas accessibles
aux commandes des touristes et donc on a
eu accès à ces blocs qui sont gardés
dans l'état et donc ça c'est moi qui
marche sur les sur le petit parquet avec
mon enregistreur en faisant plusieurs
types de vitesses et j'ai voulu aussi
que voilà il y a ce moment de de silence
pour que il y ait une évocation une
évocation de
en plus c'était un bloc avec
un truc de
Noël dans l'univers cinématographique et
par rapport à la fiction quelle place
devrait prendre ce documentaire ce
documentaire là il a réalisé avec
énormément de rigueur
que tout est une allégorie de la Shoah
d'ailleurs premier X-Men et deux autres
comment ça auschwitt tu vois c'est une
allégorie de la Shoah et même des
allégories du racisme de l'homophobie de
tout ce que vous voulez en termes de
rejet et
un film comme ça
et beaucoup moins exigeant à priori pour
le public un film qui le pianiste qui
est un super bon film et quand on va
voir le pénis on va avoir un film sur
l'événement et donc on sait à quoi on
est confronté on va voir X-Men on va
voir un film débile de super-héros et
pourtant le propos est loin d'être
débile voilà mais c'est pour ça que le
rapport à la fiction il est très
compliqué
d'abord pour les historiens il y en a
beaucoup qui aiment pas la fiction et
aussi pour le spectateur il y a peu de
spectateurs qui se disent la fiction que
je suis en train de voir en fait elle me
parle d'histoire alors que ça peut
souvent être le cas
est-ce que les alliés
n'ont réagi face ce qui se passait alors
que même qu'ils avaient conscience
puisqu'il recevait les rapports de
pileeski et des autres résistants
polonais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors
c'est une très bonne question que je
trouve totalement légitime et qui est
totalement
anachronique et à historique pour une
raison très simple si vous regardez une
carte de l'Europe en 1942 toute l'Europe
est dominée par un pays qui s'appelle
l'Allemagne nazie
de Bayonne à Moscou et du coup qu'est-ce
que vous voulez faire pour aller très
vite et très simplement en 1942 vous
pouvez pas bombarder aux fuites il y a
les Anglais tout seul sur leur île il y
a les Soviétiques qui défendent Moscou
voilà ce que c'est il faut attendre 1944
et l'été 1944 pour voir les Alliés
potentiellement pouvoir bombarder aux
chutes les t44 maintenant question très
simple et à nouveau l'actualité nous le
montre les Russes passent leur temps à
nous vanter leur magnifique missiles
ultra moderne qui peuvent taper
n'importe quel voiture ou n'importe quel
bâtiment et ça tape une école ils disent
non mais on n'a pas fait exprès est-ce
que vous pensez qu'en 1944 avec les
bombes de l'époque on peut réussir à
atteindre une cible facilement
donc bombarder aux Schmitt ça revient à
tuer les prisonniers
donc
toutes les questions de pourquoi les
alliés n'ont rien fait elles se
comprennent par
l'humanisme enfin plein de choses mais
c'est des questions qui sont
à historiques au sens de est-ce qu'elle
se pose comme ça à l'époque et déjà même
avant que ça est-ce que c'est possible
jusqu'à l'été 44 c'est clairement pas
possible du tout et à partir de l'été 44
en fait ça change plus grand chose parce
que le plus gros de l'histoire réalisé
donc il faut vraiment faire attention à
ce truc là les alliés n'ont rien fait
bah si les avions quand même battu le
Troisième Reich l'Italie de Mussolini et
quelques autres pays alliés avec eux et
ont fini par libérer les camps ce qui a
mis un terme à toute cette histoire là
et c'est ça surtout l'essentiel du
propose
que le plus important c'est d'écrire son
rapport pour témoigner de ce qu'il a vu
et vécu
avec cette ultime rapport pile est ce
qui veut achever son témoignage
puis il reprend les armes pour combattre
le Reich
[Musique]
le personnage de vittold la pile esquive
est-ce que pour vous c'est un héros
oui Gabriel et puis je trouve que c'est
surtout un héros pour ces valeurs et
notamment je crois que c'est dans
l'avant-propos de son rapport il dit ou
dans une lettre qu'il adresse à son
commandant je crois il dit qu'il veut
qu'il ne veut pas vendre son témoignage
parce que pour lui enfin c'est pas un
objet de commerce et c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très fort et donc rien
que le fait de se livrer enfin d'aller à
Auschwitz par amour pour sa patrie mais
aussi pour défendre une Pologne libre et
le fait de ne pas vouloir vendre ce
qu'il a vécu là-bas ça montre bien qu'il
avait des valeurs et pour moi un héros
c'est avant tout des valeurs Joséphine
c'est encore plus un héros parce que
après avoir vécu à Auschwitz ensuite il
se bat pour sous l'Union soviétique pour
cette vision de la Pologne libre donc il
continue son action après
tout ce qu'il a vécu après toute
l'horreur qu'il a vu et c'est incroyable
c'est surtout un courage exceptionnel de
cette fait volontairement arrêter pour
aller voir ce qui se passait enfin tout
le monde ne serait pas prêt à faire ça
même pour la résistance enfin c'est
quand même une action d'une grandeur si
je peux dire est-ce que vous n'avez pas
eu peur de de rentrer dans la banalité
en traitant le thème d'Oche Fitz qui est
incontournable peut-être quelqu'un qui
vole le titre du documentaire se dit je
vais peut-être regarder un autre puisque
je connais déjà beaucoup de choses sur
Auschwitz tal brutman vous en pensez
quoi
vous pensez que il y a plein de trucs
qui rechent il y en a quasiment pas
c'est aussi simple que ça
en France il y a deux livres
d'historiens qui ont été écrits sur
Auschwitz un par un être vivorka et un
par mois
vous voyez que Auschwitz que vous pensez
ultra traiter il y a d'autres livres qui
ont été traduits mais
Auschwitz on connaît à travers des
témoignages on a l'impression qu'on en
parle tout le temps mais en fait c'est
on le connaît très très mal et tout à
l'heure quand je vous ai dit que vous
connaissez Malo shit c'est pas parce que
j'ai envie que vous connaissiez mal
aussi c'est qu'on connaîtrez mal il y a
pas beaucoup de documentaires sur vous
avez l'impression qu'il y en a plein
mais des vrais documentaires
c'est-à-dire qui traitent d'Auschwitz
d'une manière ou d'une autre il y en a
relativement peu comparé à la place que
je suis occupe dans la mémoire
européenne et l'importance que ça en
résonance y compris dans vos
représentations enfin qui sont non
représentations ou pour tout un chacun
ici Auschwitz ça représente quelque
chose et évidemment et là j'ai témoigner
avant de m'arrêter souvent quand j'ai
affaire à des maisons de production pour
des projets de documentaire et on parle
d'Auschwitz avec des radiateurs et
maisons prodes nous disent encore alors
c'est des trucs qui ont jamais été
traités jamais j'aurais savoir comment
la famille
le fait que vous
faire un documentaire sur vital depuis
le ski est-ce qu'elle a accepté
directement aisément ou est-ce que il y
a eu peut-être de l'appréhension
il a fallu montrer pas de planche donc
il a fallu écrire une lettre et donc là
vous en doutez c'est le retour de ma
gentil maman qui prend ma lettre qui
pense faisait trois ou quatre pages et
qui traduit et qui traduit pourquoi
est-ce que on s'intéresse à ce sujet
nous Français qu'est-ce qu'on veut en
raconter avec ce que disait tal Portman
avec cette question de on est quel bord
politique qu'est-ce qu'on raconte et
donc nous on a expliqué que ce qu'on
voulait savoir c'était qui était little
pileeski et que nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'était au sud parce que le
fil conducteur en fonte ce film aussi
c'est la création de de ce camp qui
d'abord est une caserne militaire
polonaise qui se transforme en prison à
ciel ouvert quand et ensuite c'est la
mise en place de la machine de mort nazi
c'est ça qu'on raconte en toile de fond
plus en réalité que uniquement vitalski
ou quand comment et d'ailleurs je pense
que ça leur fera extrêmement plaisir de
voir cette scène là parce que l'un des
éléments qui qui des a convaincu c'est
que ce film pourrait être vu par par la
jeune génération aussi et que on leur
avait dit que nous on aimerait bien
qu'il soit vu par des écoliers par des
collégiens par des lycéens et ils ont
trouvé que que l'idée était très
intéressante et que voilà c'est aussi
intéressant pour pour la jeune
génération
d'avoir cette histoire merci infiniment
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous les élèves vous pouvez vous abonner
bravo pour toutes vos questions vos
réflexions et puis merci à vous à vos
professeurs évidemment professeurs de
français votre CPE nous avoir permis de
réaliser ce magnifique programme et puis
vous aussi si vous voulez participer à Z
la Zone d'Éducation documentaire vous
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire à nous
envoyer un email on y répondra
évidemment avec plaisir en attendant Zed
revient avec une nouvelle classe et un
nouveau documentaire parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour questionner le monde et
ces images allez salut les élèves
ça c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]